انها 8:00 مساء بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نص وهذا الشرايير وهذه
اخبار الساعه
في ايران النظام يحجب الانترنت مجددا
ورصاصه الامني يقتل 60 طفلا والعفو
الدوليه تنشر الاسماء والصور
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الاكراد يشيعون قتلى الغارات التركيه
والعربيه ترصد التوتر على الحدود
حينخذه بالاكراد في رؤيه كردستانهم
الموعوده وعمليات تركيا المستمره لاجهاضه
تبقى هذه البقعه من الارض ساحه مفتوحه
للقتل والقتال
وزيرو طاقه السعوديه في تقارير عن زياده
الانتاج بمقدار 500000 برميل يوميا ويؤكد
استمرار التخفيض حتى 2023
زلزال اندونيسيا يحصد مزيدا من الارواح
الخسائر البشريه فاقت ال 160 وقراب
والثلاثه عشر الفنانات
[موسيقى]
اوقات المشاهدين الكرام اهلا بكم في اخبار
الساعه التي نبداوها من ايران ورغم عمليات
القمع التي يمارسها النظام الايراني على
المحتاجين لا تزالوا الاحتجاجات تعم
مختلفه المدن الايرانيه وباشكال واساليب
متعدده لكن بهدف واحد رفعوا ظلم النظام
عنهم حيث شهدت عشرات المدن مظاهرات تضامنا
مع مدينه مهاباد الكرديه بعد تقارير حذرت
من ارتكاب مجازر وقمع غير مسبوق كما اظهرت
مقاطع فيديو وعمليات كر وفر واطلاق نار في
مدينه جوار رود الكرديه ما ادى الى مقتل
واصابه برصاص الامن وقبل قليل المشاهدين
اكد موقع بلوكس لمراقبه الانترنت حدوث
تعطل كبير في الخدمه في ايران فقال الموقع
على تويتر ان الانترنت عبر الهاتف المحمول
مقطوعه عن العديد من المستخدمين في ايران
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اصوات النمر
على مدى عقود كان ثمنها حياتهم اذ اعلنت
منظمه هارون شطئ حقوق الانسان في البلاد
ان عدد قتلى الاحتجاجات ارتفع الى 419
قتيلا على الاقل من بينهم 60 طفلا بعضهم
لا يتجاوز الثمان سنوات في معتقل النظام
الايراني ما لا يقل عن
17451 متظاهرا بينهم ما لا يقل عن 540
طالبا في 150 مدينه ايراني»
هذا ونشرت منظمه العفو الدوليه فيديو
يتضمن اسماء الاطفال الذين قتلتهم قوه
الامن الايرانيه وذلك بعد اندلاع
الاحتجاجات في المحافظات والمدن الايرانيه
منذ ما يزيد عن ثلاثه اشهر نتامه
[موسيقى]
انت يا بشير
انا
[موسيقى]
وتواصلوا الاحتجاجات في العديد من المناطق
شمال وغرب ايران دفع النظام الايراني لنقل
وحده من الحرس الثوري والقوات الخاصه الى
مدينه مهاباد الكرديه في اذربيجان الغربيه
الايرانيه اصدار حكم اخر بالاعدام ضد احد
المتظاهرين لانه قام باغلاق شارعي ستار
خان في طهران وايقاف السياره
السادسه عشره من سبتمبر الماضي بدا نقطه
تتحول في ايران القصه بدات بضربه قاتله
تلقاها راس الفتاه العشرينيات الكرديه
الايرانيه مهسا اميني داخل مركز شرطه
الاخلاق في العاصمه طهران اثرات قالها
بحجه عدم ارتدائها الحجاب الكامل في اليوم
التالي وبعد الاعلان عن وفاه امين خرجت
احتجاجات شعبيه عفويه في مسقط راسها
لتنتقل الى سائر المدن الكرديه
عشرات المدن الايرانيه الكبيره في مختلف
المحافظات وخرج الالاف من اصفهان في الوسط
الى مشهد في الشمال الشرقي مرورا بالشراز
جنوبا ورشت في الشمال وفي محافظه بلوشستان
خرج الاهالي الى الشوارع وواجههم الامن
بالرصاص الحي مع اسفر عن ما يقارب 90
قتيلا من البلوش
النساء والفتيات التي حملت الاحتجاجات
وشعارا ينصب على مطالبهن اولا النساء
الحياه الحريه يشاركنا بقوه في تلك
الاحتجاجات مئات الطلاب في اكثر من 142
جامعه دفعوا خارج بواباتها واغلقت المحل
تجاريه مرارا ابوابها للتضامن مع
المحتاجين بالاضافه الى مشاركه اطباء
ومخرجين وفنانين ورياضيين واعلاميين منهم
من شارك على الارض واخرون الحاذ بمواقفهم
علنا الى جانب شعبهم في العشرين من نوفمبر
الجاري تجددت الاحتجاجات في المدن الكرديه
غربي ايران ونقلت السلطات وحدات الحرس
الثوري الايراني والقوات الخاصه الى مدينه
مهابات الكرديه في اذربيجان الغربيه وبعد
يوم واحد على قمر معها بعد خرجت تظاهرات
حاشده شهدتها مدينتاج واندرويد شهر
الكرديتان غربي ايران ردا النظام على
المحتاجين باطلاق النار بشكل مباشر وعبر
القناصه وشاهدت مدينه بوشهر هي الاخرى
التي تقع جنوبيه ايران على الخليج مظاهره
حاشده امام مقر المحافظه وردت قوات الامن
على المحتاجين بالقاء الغاز المثيلي
للدموع حنان المصري العربيه
معنا من لندن
اهلا بك معنا العربيه اسالك بدايه عن قطع
الانترنت ما الذي علمتيها حول قطع النظام
للانترنت في ايران وكيف يتمكن الايرانيون
من التغلب على الحجم
هذه مياده
قطع الانترنت باتت جزءا لا يتجزا من عمليه
الطمع التي يقدم عليها النظام لذا كنا
نلاح
الانترنت وسبب في ذلك هو رغبه النظام في
عرق التي تدفق المعلومات واستخدامها وكذلك
المحتوى الخاص بالمستخدمين الذي يخرج من
ايران وقد تكون تلك هي الطريقه الوحيده او
المسار الوحيد لمعرفه لاخبار الناس خارج
ايران عما يدور في البلاد
مظاهرات والحكومه في ايران كانت تفعل هذا
الامر وهو ليس بحديث العهد بل هي ممارسه
قديمه
والمتظرون للاسف لا توجد لديهم الادوات او
السبب التغلب على هذه المحنه ما لم
تساعدهم الاسره الدوليه في ذلك
لحظه المستخدمون يقومون باستخدام بالفي بي
ان من اجل
يتسنى لهم
التواصل على شبكات التواصل الاجتماعيه ومن
خلال بعض الشبكات مثل الانستغرام وتويتر
وفيسبوك وغيرها لذا في حقيقه الامر ان
النظام يسعى لصديق الخناق على ال ال الشعب
بصوره رقميه وعلى الارض وفضلاع عن
العمليات القمع العسكريه
اطفال كثر كنا قدر راينا من خلال تخرج عن
ما يصل الى 50 طفل
التي قتلت الانترنت ليست جديده على
المقاطعه بالحديث القتله وضحايا القمع في
ايران في اليومين الاخيرين شاهدنا حمل
حمله قمع كبيره يقوم بها النظام خاصه في
المحافظات الكرديه التي طبع الكردي في
شمال وفي غرب ايران هل تعتقدين ان الثوره
بحكم انه ماسه امي كانت كرديه همم هل هذه
الاحتجاجات تاخذ بعدا كرديا اكثر ام لا هي
تمسك كل الشعب الايراني
اقول ان هذا صحيح
قد تحدثت عن ان كردستان هي ثاني منطقه في
ايران التي تحتوي على اكبر عدد من الوفيات
والا فضلا عن اعتقالات لدى صديق الخناق في
هذه المنطقه بيعدوا كبيرا وسبب يعود الى
تاريخ الثوره فشعب الكردي كان قويا وكان
يحارب النظام ووحشيته
كيكر شيب همم الخاصه
بالنظام ولهذا فان الاخير
فانه لم يعد لهذا الشعب اي شيء ليخسره هو
اليوم بات لدينا
عن مركبات ومئات الجنود الذين تم نشرهم في
تلك المناطق
وفي بما في ذلك مدينه مهبل وجوان وخلال
الساعات الاربعه والعشرين الماضيه ووفقا
لمجموعه حقوق الانسان التابعه لكره القدم
مواطن الكرديا قتلوا ما هو سبب في ذلك
لانه كان يناشدون مطالب بهم بالحريه وهم
لا يمتلكون اي سلاح او اي شيء من هذا
القبيل لذا هم لا يشكلنا اي تهديدا على
النظام بل شهر وما يرغبون هو تحقيق
المساواه والحريه وهذه المنطقه كانت مهمشه
منذ فتره طويله منذ مجيء الثوره الاسلاميه
هذه المنطقه باتت اكثر المناطق صعوبه
وريني الباك بوكس همم
وعصيانا
وكذلك تخلفا من الناحيه الاقتصاديه في
البلاد وهذا ما شاهدناه من خلال العقود
الماضيه اليوم نرى ايضا عمليات تضييق
خناقه كبيره ولهذا فان مجموعات حقوق
الانسان تهيب بالمدن الاخرى بما في ذلك
اصبحا ومن في ذلك كافه المناطق الاقليميه
ولا في ازربيجان ان تاتي لمؤاثرتهم لان
النظام وقوات الحرس الثوري يركزون في
الفتره الحاليه من خلال عمليات قمع واسعه
في كافه اقليم كردستان بما في ذلك
شكرا جزيلا انت صحفيه الايرانيه كنت معنا
من لندن
[موسيقى]
ونذهب الى سوريا الان حيث تشيع الاكراد
اليوم في مدينه درك شمال شرق سوريا
التي تحدثت بناطقهم ليله السبت الماضي
وتوعد المشيعون بالانتقام لقتلاهم خلال
المراسم التي حضرها نحو عشره الف شخص
صرخاتهن للالم
لفقدان اثني عشر شخصا قتلتهم تركيا في
غارات جويه على الاكراد ليله السبت
المنصرم
بمزيد من من يفارقون احبتهم وذويهم مدنيون
وعسكريون وصحفيون
قتلوا في الضربات التركيه الاخيره
ماذا فعلنا لهم لم نهاجمهم ولم نسرق
اموالهم لماذا يهاجموننا نحن على ارضنا
وفي وطننا لذلك لا نعرف اي تفسير لصمت
الدول الكبرى
[موسيقى]
تخطن شعبي
بالرد على الغارات التركيه في الوقت
المناسب وربما تكون العمليتان العسكريتان
في كل تركيا
حين حلم الاكراد في رؤيه كردستانهم
الموعوده وعمليات تركيا المستمره تبقى هذه
البقعه من الارض ساحه مفتوحه للقتل
والقتال مع غياب اي افقد لحلول سياسيه او
عسكريه تنهي هذا الصراع من مدينه شمال
سوريا
[موسيقى]
كان هذا بالنسبه للاكراد في سوريا اما في
العراق اكدت وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه ان
الهجمات التركيه والايرانيه بالمسيرات
والصواريخ التي استهدفت اقليم كردستان
العراق تخالف المواثيق الدوليه وتعد خرقا
لسياده العراق كما عبرتها على ان تكون
الاراضي العراقيه ساحه لتصفيه الحسابات مع
اطراف الخارجي
على محافظه اربيل بالصواريخ والطائرات
المسيره فجر اليوم الاثنين رفض عبدالله
سياده الوطنيه
هذا ولوح الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
بالتواغل البري في شمال العراق وسوريا
ونقلت وسائل الاعلام التركيه عن اردوغان
قوله ان العمليات لن تقتصر على الغارات
الجويه وان هناك مناقشات تجري لبحث مشاركه
القوات البريه
معنا من اربيل عبد السلام البرواري النائب
السابق في البرلمان الكردستاني عن الحزب
الديمقراطي
الكردستاني ساعه النائب اهلا بكم معنا في
اخبار الساعه من العربيه كيف تنظرون الى
تلويح الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
بعمليه في شمال سوريا وفي العراق ايضا في
شمال العراق
نعم تحيه لكم المشاهدين المشاهدات في
الحقيقه تعودنا كل ما جابها النظام التركي
مشكله او احتاج الى دفع
لتجميع الناس ورفع مستوى يعني التفافهم
حول الحكومه يقومون بمثل هذه العملليات
اذا كانت العمليه في الاراضي السوريه حسب
اي منطقه معينه نتيجه ما حدث في اسطنبول
فليس هناك اي مبرر للقيام
كردستان حيث منذ سنوات لم يقم حزب العمال
باي عام نشاط عبر الحدود والترك تقريبا
مسيطرين كما الايرانيون ايضا على طول
اشتريت الحدود اللي هو مواقع عسكريه وحتى
تواجد مجموعات المسلحه حدث بعد اتفاق في
كانت بوادر عمليه سلام
الاطراف كلها تم تقريبا السماح اللي حوالي
كم الف مقاتل من مقاتلي حزب العمال بان
يتوجهوا الى الاراضي العراقيه ان هذه
الاقليم ولكن
كذلك حتى نفهم الصوره كذلك ما يحدث في
كردستان العراق يعني المشكله مزدوجه هناك
قصف ايراني وقصف تركي وهو ليس من اليوم
يعني منذ فتره وهذا القصف موجود لماذا
يقصف الايرانيون والاطراف كردستان العراق
انا
اعبر عن هذا المساء انا اعتقد هذه كلها
رسائل الداخل الايراني والداخل العراق همم
التركي
تزعزعت الثقه بالحكومه بعد حادث اسطنبول
مواضيع مثل تعديل الدستور مشكله ترشيح
اردوغان هذه المحاولات الجاريه في يعني
تجميع تحالف يضمن له من الفوز ومحاولات
المعارضه
في ايران تعرفون يعني شهرين الشعب منتظر
فاضل الشعب يعلم بكل صراحه همم ينادي
باسقاط بالكاتون والشعارات ضد الخميني
وهناك اكله باستمرار همم
نظامين يحتاجون الرساله
الحكومات الشموليه والحكومات المتساقطه
بان
تقوم بعمليات همم المواطنينها
كدليل على قوتها وعلى همم سيطرتها على
الوضع والا يعني حتى بالنسبه للسكان
يقوم ببعض العمليات لكن الاحزاب الكرديه
الموجوده في كردستان العراق منذ 80 ريال
توعدت ووفت بوعدها بان لا تقوم باي عمل
عبر الحدود يقبل ايراني مبرر لا يعمل
عسكريه اشكركم شكرا جزيلا من اربيل كنتم
معنا الاستاذ عبد السلام البرواري النائب
السابق في البرلمان الكردستانيه عن الحزب
الديمقراطيه الكردستاني
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه في جديد ازمه
تويتر ترقبوا لموجه اقالات اليوم تفاصيلها
مع مراسيلنا من سان فرانسيسكو حسين الطول
بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نفى وزير الطاقه
السعوديه الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان بشكل
نقاطع التقارير التي تفيد بان المملكه
تناقش زياده انتاج النفط بمقدار 500,000
برميل يوميا واكد الامير عبد العزيز بن
سلمان ان خفض الانتاج الحليب بمقدار
مليونيرمي يوميا مستمر حتى نهايه عام 2023
وقال وزير الطاقه السعودي انه من المعروف
لا تبحث اي قرارات قبل استماعتها واشار
الى الاستعداد للتدخل واجراء اجراءات او
اتخاذ اجراءات اخرى لخفض الانتاج للموازنه
بين العرض والطلب عند الحاجه
من جانبه نفا وزير الطاقه الاماراتيه سهيل
المزروعي مشاركه الامارات في اي مناقشه مع
اعضاء اوبيك بس بشان قرار خفض الانتاج
الساري حتى اخر عام 2023 واكد سهيل
المزروعي التزام دوله الامارات بهدف اوفيس
لدعم التوازن في سوق النفط وقال سندعم اي
قرار لتحقيق هذا الهدف
[موسيقى]
ونذهب الان الى الحرب الاوكرانيه سلسله من
الانتصارات في هذا الخريف لكيف جعلت الحرب
في اوكرانيا تتجه الى نقطه انعطف اخرى
تقرير لصحيفه واشنطن بوست اكد ان القوه
الاوكرانيه تواجه عقبات تهدد بابطاء
التقدم حيث يستعد كل جانب بيستعد لمواصله
القتال ولا يقترب اي من الجانبين مما
يتصوره على انه انتصار واشنط نقلت عن
عسكريين اوكرانيين قولهم ان المعركه
الصعبه ستكون خارجه وهي مدينه على اطراف
[موسيقى]
متابع التطورات مع مراسيلينا من نيكولايف
حذيفه
قراءه الاخبار
تحياتي صهيب يعني نيكولايف الان تعيش وضع
لساني صعب جدا الان المدينه كما تشاهد في
الظلام دامس جميع
الاحياء تعاني هناك قطاعات كبيره جدا في
مناطق واسعه في مدينه مكلايف للكهرباء
والمياه وامدادات الغاز طبعا ايضا هنالك
نقص في امدادات الغذاء ليس فقط في
نيكولايب ولكن ايضا في منطقه الجنوب بشكل
عام والاسيه طبعا منطقه خرسون اليوم زار
هذه المدينه السيد مادي وهو سفير الاتحاد
الاوروبي والتقى بالعمده عمده المدينه
والتقى ايضا برئيس الاداره العسكريه في
ايطاليا
بحث سبل همم دعم هذه المنطقه هنا في
الجنوب التي طبعا استعاده القوات
الاوكرانيه السيطره على كامل الحدود
الاداريه لهذه الولايه حديثا بتحرير منطقه
صغيره جدا هي شيء في الجزيره الان ما زال
يسيطر عليها الروس هنالك تواجد القوات
الروسيه ومن هذه المنطقه يتيم قصف هذه
المقاطعه كما نتاليا جومي لوكان انه اليوم
كان هادئا طبعا بالامس كان اخر قصف لهذه
المدينه في الظهيره بعد ذلك همم يعني كانت
ليله هادئه في ميكا لايف وايضا واليوم همم
قضت هذه المدينه ايضا نهار هذه والان
القصف يتمركز في منطقه اخر سون اليوم تم
قصف مركز المدينه وكان هنالك عدد من
القتلى والجرحى هذا من الجانب الاوكراني
ماذا عن الجانب الروسي رائد اسالك الوضع
عندكم هناك وهمم التطورات العسكريه كذلك
في دنياك
صهيب قبل الحديث
لابد من الاشاره عن الى تصريحات الجانب
الموالي لروسيا في زاباروجا الذي اكد ان
القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت المحطه النوويه
باكثر من 10 دقائق كانت تصيب المباني ما
بين المبنى الثاني والخامس واظهر فيديو
نشره زعيم الشيشانيين رمضان هذا
المحور لكن المحور ايضا صراعات وهمم يعني
حروب معارك بين مد وجزر ما بين القوات
الاخرانيه
والروسيه القوات المواليه لروسيا بفصائلها
المختلفه مثل اصبرتات وايضا صومالي همم
تقدمت خلف المطار خلف مدينه ميسي ورفعت
الاعلام الروسيه كما انها تتقدم في المحور
الجنوبي وتشير الى سيطرتها على بعض
البلدان كما اسلفت في التقرير هنا
ما بين
همم المقاطعه المجاوره وهي همم لوغانس في
منطقه سبابا فعلا هي الاكثر خطوره والاكثر
سخونه حيث تشير الدفاع الروسيه الى قتل
مئات جنود الاوكرانيين الذين ينفدون
عمليات مداهمه واقتحام وتدمير عشرات
الاليات في هذا المحضر نعم جزيلا لكما
مراسله العربيه اذا رائد الاخبار من
الدنيا وحذيفه عادل من ميرايز
[موسيقى]
اذا هو مشاهديناوه الى هذا الخبر العاجل
اذا البرلمان الاوروبي يعلن وقفه اي اتصال
مباشر مع البرلمان الايراني حتى اشعار اخر
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه نتبع بدايه فصل
الشتاء مفاجئه في المانيا والثلوج تغطي
ثلاثه
مرحبا من جديد حاله وصفت بالجنونيه
التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر منذ تولى
الملياردير الامريكي
قراراته فصل والغاء عقود عده اتخذها ماسك
بحق الموظفين توالت معها استقالات
لموظفينا الاداريين اخرها المدير العام
لفرع تويتر في فرنسا
دون ان يضحي ما اذا كان قد استقال من
تلقاء نفسه او ارغم على مغادره المنصه
العموم نذهب الى المقر الرئيسي لشركه
تويوتا
حسين جديد ازمه تويتر
تحيه لك صهيب بالفعل حاله غموض تلف ااا
الموضوع اليوم اليوم الاثنين كان من
المفترض ان يعود الموظفون الى هذا المبنى
المبنى الرئيسي هنا في سان فرانسيسكو
نشاهد احد الموظفين او احد المهندسين الذي
يعملون به حتى الان منذ ساعات الصباح
الاولى لم نشاهد اي موظف يدخل او يخرج
تابع لتويتر هناك طبعا همم اماكن عده تدخل
بها اشخاص عاديون ولكن موظفات لم نرى منهم
اي احد حتى الان حاولت الاقتراب من همم
المبنى الرئيسي او البوابه الرئيسيه تويتر
طبعا همم تحدث معي عندما عرفوا انني صحفي
قالوا لي علي علي انا ابقى بعيده انا ابقى
في الشارع لان انا في الشارع هذا ملكيه
عموميه في الداخل يسمح لي فقط بالدخول اذا
كان همم ليس لدي كاميرا او لا ادخل بصفه
صحفيه هذا هنا يمكن الوقوف عنده بعدها
نمنع منها الاقتراب همم
الى الداخل طالما نحن نحمده الكاميرا كان
من امر من المتوقع ان يعلن اليوم عن اقامه
ايضا عدد من الموظفين خاصه الموظفين في
قسم المبيعات وفي قسم التسويق ولكن حتى
الان لم يخرج اي قرار ولم نسمع باي قرار
في انتظار ان نسمع ذلك الان قيل انا سالت
بعض موظفين استقبال في الداخل الذين قبلوا
ان يتحدثوا معي سالتهم هل يوجد هل رايتم
احد الموظفين يدخل او يخرج قالوا نعتقد
انه هناك اجتماع سيكون بعد الظهر انا في
الانتظار يعني ارى ما هي اخر التطورات كان
هناك عدد من الاعلاميين ايضا موجودين في
هذا الشارع الان ذهبوا همم ربما لانهم
ايضا لم لم يستطيع ان لم يروا احدا همم
كما قلت صهيب هي هي حاله من من تلف المكان
لا نعرف ماذا يجري لا نعرف اذا كان سيتم
فاصل او همم طرد او شيء من هذا القبيل
حسين طول مباشره من شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى اجواء كاس العالم حيث يشهد منفذ
سلوى الحدوديه الرابط بين السعوديه وقطر
استمرار توافذ الاف المشجعين الراغبين
بحضور مباريات بطوله كاس العالم 2022
[موسيقى]
عبر المنفذ البري الوحيد الى كاس العالم
ينتقل الالاف من المشجعين عبر هذه
الحافلات التي يبلغ عددها ما بين 50 الى
70 في وقت الذروه وتقوم بنقل الالاف من
المشجعين من مختلف الجنسيه قبيل المباريات
تكتدو عدد من الجنسيات التي تذهب لمشاهده
مباراتها قبل اليوم تواجد كبير للجمهور
الانجليزيه قبل مباراتهم بعد ساعات همم
ساتوجه من هنا الى قطر لحضورك كاس العالم
فضلت العبور من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لانها ارخص ولانها بلد جميل للسفر وشيء
جديد ومختلف خذنا ثلاث ساعات في الصحراء
استمتعنا ولم نشعر بالملل
رائع وصحراء جميله استمتعنا والمكان مؤمن
بالكامل تنظيم ممتاز كل شيء مرتب كل شيء
على كل شيء ماشي صح
وجاي قبل المباراه بيومي عشان نشوف
الافتتاح ونشوف يعني نشوف السادات قبل
المباراه بيومين يعني انا احب السفر اولا
بالبر وتايم من البحرين لقطر ثلاث ساعات
فضلنا نجي عند سيارتي واريح لي الامور وكل
شيء مسهل الحمد لله
والامور طيبه وكل بسطه ما تشوفون
والباركات متوفره والباصات مجاني
[موسيقى]
خيارات متعدده لدى الجمهور في ايقاف
سياراتهم منها ما يقفوا ليوم واحد واخرى
باربعه ايام متواصله خدمات متنوعه تقدم
هنا سواء كان من حفظ السيارات او تنظيمها
والاتجاه مباشره الى الحافلات التي تقع
بالقرب من هذه المواقف والله ما شاء الله
البلد همم سلسه جدا والامور سهله والامور
كلها تمام ونتمنى الفوز للمنتخب السعودي
[موسيقى]
تعاون سعودي القطريين مباشر عبر هذه
السلسله التي تبدا بهذه الحافلات ولا
تنتهي عند منفذ ابو سمره بل تستمر الى ان
تصل بهؤلاء المشجعين الى قلب الدوحه سلسله
متواصله من التعاون السعودي القطري لتسهيل
وصول الجماهير الى الملاعب ووصولهم الى
كاس العالم عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه
ومن قلب الدوحه معنا فهد الشهري منفذ
العربيه فهد اهلا بك معنا موعد مصيري تحبس
عنده الانفاس غدا مباراه الارجنتين
والسعوديه في عند الثانيه ظهرا ما الذي
تمكنت رصده الاجواء همم توافد المشجعين
السعوديين همم خاصه عبر الحدود البريه الى
الدوحه
نعم مساء الخير عليكم متابعين النشره في
قناه العربيه نعم توفد الجمهور السعودي
بكثافه اليوم وايضا ليس الحضور الاخير
سيكون ايضا تواجد للجمهور السعودي من صباح
الغد من خلال رحلات الجويه وايضا المنافذ
البريه
للدوحه لمؤازره المنتخب السعودي نعم حضور
كثير تشجيع دائم حماس همم نشر الثقافات
السعوديه ايضا من خلال المشجع السعودي
والاهزيج السعوديه وايضا همم توثيق هذه
اللحظات وايصالها للعالم كله ايضا ايصالها
بطريقه غير مباشره للاعب السعودي من اجل
اظهار حماس وتحقيق النتيجه ايجابيه في يوم
الثلاثاء
الخاص بالجمهور السعودي همم
قدام صحيح
نعم نحن الان في البيت السعودي البيت
السعودي في الدوحه تم اقامته التزامنا مع
هذه التظاهر الكبيره كاس العالم الذي يفد
لها الجميع من جميع دول العالم البيت
السعودي يضم 12 قسم وايضا يضم 20 22
فعاليه منتشره تنقل التراويح
سعوديين هل بامكان ان تجول بين الكاميرا
قليلا للمشاهد طبعا الاهازيج والاحتفالات
السعوديه استعدادا للقاء التاريخي غدا بين
السعوديه والارجنتين
نعم الجمهور السعودي يتواجد هنا بشكل دائم
من بدايه النهار حيث افتتح هذا المكان
دائما في الحادي عشر صباحا ويتم اغلاقه
بعد تقريبا ثلث ساعه في الثانيه عشر
بتوقيت الدوحه اا قسم ونواع في عدد من
نشاطات في النشاطات الترفيهيه وفي ايضا
التحديات من خلال كره القدم وفي ايضا
العديد من النتائج الخاصه بشعارات
والسعوديه وايضا متاحف لابرز الانجازات
الانديه الانجازات المنتخب السعودي من
خلال التاريخ همم ايضا في همم العديد من
الاماكن الترفيهيه اللي يوجد فيها المشجع
السعودي وغير السعودي ايضا انا شاهد
مشجعين غير السعوديين اذا كما تشاهد هذا
يعني احد مشجعين من دوله المغرب
نعم اي نعم يحضر هنا نعم انا جهه عقيقه
العديد من المشجعين من الدول اللي حتى
حضروا يبحثوا عن تذاكر المباراه مع
المنتخب السعودي الارجنتيني هذا تقريبا
يعني محمد بن سلمان هل من تقديرات لاعداد
المشجعين السعوديين خاصه الذين سيتبعون
المباراه غدا
ظهر الغد
بالنسبه للملعب اعتقد انه راح يكون كامل
الساعه من خلال
المشجع السعودي والمشجعتيني الارجنتيني
الجمهور السعودي يقدر يعني المسؤوليه
السعوديين من خلال العدد الرسمي اللي تم
قلبه من خلال النقل البري ونقل الجوي
بحوالي 13.000 مشجعه رسمي غير ما تبقى
وغير من يحضر ان شاء الله خلال ساعات
القادمه لمتابعه المنتخب السعودي وتشجيعه
امام المرشح الاول لتحقيق كاس العالم
المنتخب الارجنتيني وهو تحدي كبير جدا
نتمنى التوفيق للاخضر همم المنتخب السعودي
لانه كذلك هو اول منتخب عربي يقابل
الارجنتين يعني وهو اول ماتش او اول
مباراه في هذا يعني مهما ستكون صعبه همم
اذا همم تحدي همم كبير همم نتمنى ان يكون
ال- همم المنتخب السعودي في همم اذا في
همم قمه اعطائه اذن مع هذا التحدي الكبير
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه الصوره الحقيقه اذا
من الدوحه فهد الشهري مفرد العربيه
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى اندونيسيا حيث قال حاكم مدينه
جاوا الغربيه رضوان كامل ان الزلزال الذي
ضرب الجزيره اصفر عن مقتل نحو 260 شخصا
واصاب اكثر من 326 مشيرا في الوقت ذاته
انه تم اجلاء حوالي ثلاثه عشر الف شخص من
الدمر
326 شخصا واصيب معظمهم بكثور في العظام او
اصيبوا بسبب سقوط الاجسام واصابات الشقوق
وكان هناك ايضا حوالي
13,000,784 شخصا ثم اجلهائهم
[موسيقى]
شهدت المانيا بدايه المفاجاه لفصل الشتاء
حيث تساقط الثلوج بشكل كثيف في ولايات كل
من سكتونيا وهيثم وترنج النواب رائعه ووصل
معدل سقوط معدل سقوط الثلج في جبال ولايه
بافاريا الى 15 سنتيمترا مما غطا امام
الماره المناظر الطبيعيه المعتاده للولايه
ومن جهه اخرى صرح مسؤولون في ولايه
ساكسونيا ان درجه الحراره خفضت في الولايه
الى اقل من عشر درجات مئويه خلال يوم واحد
فقط
[موسيقى]
في هذا الزائر الابيض المبكر اذا من
المانيا
ناتي الى ختام اخبار الساعه علي هذه
الليله شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده المزيد
دائما يبقى على العربيه دوت نت وعلى
صفحتنا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]